i want winners 30 to one you hit it you
called it on the show
i'm happy my bank account's happening
i'm giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies are you giving out today
like 45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the
absolute worst put some bleeping respect
on my name
why are you even in this group chat
you're not even betting you're not gonna
tell me i'm wrong
you have no original tanks get them out
again i don't want you in here get out
of the group chat
goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the br betting group
chat
we've got locks we've got hoodies to
give away
we've got new haircuts that look amazing
and very handsome no we don't i
am burnt yes we do i am burned we've got
kelly in vegas
greg mikey lox aka mikey flops
and our canadian national treasure
cabbie richard we're giving away hoodies
all show so keep firing off your takes
in the comments
and at the end of this thing you are
going to be deciding what we are all
taking
as a family in the nba tonight that's
going to be greg's favorite bet
that's the tinny once again you're
deciding what we're betting
and drop your picks in the comments
throughout the show
all right we will be picking the winner
and let's get into it now it's time hey
burn burn wait burt
before we get to braun and dame and luca
and the beard i've been texting
both you and mikey lox for baseball and
murphy picks since the beginning wait
cabbie you texted them and you just it's
been awesome
and you well they're the nerfy guys
they're fair they are the guys no okay
okay i listen i've already heard enough
why am i hold on wait i literally served
no purpose kels hold on i s
i'm starting to feel insecure because i
message these guys every single day so
fellas am i texting too much cabbie
cabbie you're good you're good
somebody with bad vibes low v would
maybe say hey cab we actually post these
pics every day on twitter and instagram
on locky town but that's not check the
feed
but that's not me i've got good vibes i
love you every time you text me it makes
me happy i love to talk to you
and you're the good luck charm i don't
think we've ever lost a nerf you when
we've both
been on it so kev you're good keep
texting me but you can also check your
feet i wasn't sure
nothing nothing you
worms you totally lose my heart more
than when you text me that's just what i
want to say it makes me smile
greg he touched me i hate him no no i
was just going to mention cabbie you
totally
just did not mention that you tit me up
you hit me up all the time
for bets for pigs
i'm becoming that guy who is messaging
like i hit up greg for bets
sometimes kelly's placed a couple of
bets for me so
just let me know when i'm being
obnoxious because we're in the group
chat and it's always
you're being obnoxious right now vern
start the show let's get to the show
one one you take every once we got three
olea games about to tip off all right
all right
we've got a bunch of nba games coming we
got to get into it
do you guys have any underdog picks to
win the series out right here
i do i'm in a deep dark hole that i'm
going to get out of
and the way i'm going to get out of it
is by throwing absolute darts
and hammer locks at the dogs yo the
blazer's at 41 we're gonna have to
sprinkle dinkle that one but
i actually do like the mavs 11 to 1 vern
because
uh they because you're broke and they
got lucky because you're broke and you
need to hit them
that's exactly right yes and also i want
to give a hoodie away to start
everybody in the comments let us know
what dogs you like what's the best dart
you've ever hit because i need to get
out of this but
uh who's getting the hoodie name bri
bryce strick
is someone going to tell kelly that her
shirt is stained hashtag k-state
sucks
[Laughter]
and i was like absolutely not as he can
have the ku jersey in the background so
after we got started i went and did a
quick wardrobe change i just had to
represent
vern tell the people who that is behind
you we got frank mason here
frank mason national player of the year
2020 nba g-league mvp
by the way all right how many truly give
you peace has k-state produced
i literally don't care about k-state or
kansas give me that
fire guys right now on some nba rosters
in the bubble
i am going to tell you nike locks on the
the mavericks pick
because some things that happen in game
five are not gonna happen in game six
marcus morris is not gonna try to take
out lucas ankle porzingis might be come
on
[Music]
dark place but his 35 point performance
he's not going to repeat in game six
luca doncic is a shooting star across
the sky and he's not going to have back
to back terrible performances
clippers will probably win game seven
but book it mavs in game six
guys i'm a shooting star guys guys guys
you guys like gabby and mike
kaby and mike you guys sound like the
guys that are in my dm's you guys sound
like the guys that are in my mentions
talking about
luke of this luca that luca's gonna do
this
luke is gonna do that like relax
luca is a dog don't get me wrong luca is
a dog
but it this isn't 2023 he doesn't have
the team around him yet
to win this year but with that being
said i got a lot for you guys
the oklahoma city thunder to beat the
rockets that's what i'm rocking with
the the thunder they're a young and
ferocious team shea
gil just alexander i mean like if if the
guy
scores like how he did last game if the
guy scores like how he did last game
look out the rockets are in trouble they
don't have rust even though
we just got reports that he might play
but you know if he doesn't play that's
still gonna be
not good for the rockets but anyway they
throw up more than 50 threes a game like
come on they're out there praying for
those threes that go in you're not like
praying this james harden
league i'm i'm not taking any of these
underdogs
and in fact i'm going on the rockets
because you get him at a better number
now minus 162.
russell westbrook might be playing even
if he's not him taking the rockets it
doesn't matter
rockets once again
homer i am from homer taking your home
team homer
but i also think it's a good journey
you can have both home yeah thank you
then with your heart
guys that's what we do good vibes vern
good vibes thank you all right
thank you listen i'm dying on this hill
i've been on this hill
and i i hate it i have the denver
nuggets at 24-1 to win the whole thing i
thought
hey you know what there's gonna be some
great hedge opportunities this team's
gonna go deep in the playoffs
this team is not gonna go deep in the
playoffs but i do think they should have
a shot to win the series i think this
one goes to seven
i'm gonna take the denver nuggets at
three to one and hate myself because my
nba picks have been absolute trash the
last 48 hours that's why i gotta hurry
up and get off this group chat
i got bets to make i got to get some
money back today guys
kelly the first step is acknowledging it
props to you
yeah he's a legend i got mikey i got
props to shout out
uh that shusty in the comments says
underdog of the day
vern vs baldi you get a hoodie for that
i said easiest way to win one
it's just to roast burns is he saying
about beating the underdog
jake day greg great call brother uh luca
is a dog a purebred golden retriever
who's burger five you get a hoodie for
that people are liking the mavs
they're siding with mikey locks per uge
get out of here
get out of here you definitely you are a
bozo
there's no question you just those
people clearly whatever you wanted
this is like biased selection you're
just picking out
two come on are you done is that it okay
yeah
i just wanted to call you bozo all right
now it's the time
it's time for our race to 10 pick you
guys
again you're deciding it but greg this
is your baby
all right you brought this bet into the
world you have guided us
what tinny are you looking at tonight
guys we are gonna get back in the win
column
with this one i'm feeling real confident
in the bucks and giannis
coming off winning defensive player of
the year uh the bucks they're feeling
good
i know they're feeling good orlando is
struggling to score
nobody but vucevic is putting the ball
in the bucket on their team
um give me the guarantee here i'm taking
the bucks i know it's a lot of juice
but we're going to win give me the bucks
greg you are taking a
coin flip here at minus 2 30. first
number
i'm gonna just cross that off if
anything the magic are gonna come out
hot
and then die off like they did last game
whoa but i'm just gonna stay away from
that game i'm going to take a
a little theory here we call the injured
player theory we know
portland is without dame which is why
portland is getting
such high odds here on this first really
the dumbest theory i've ever heard
why they're
it works all the time mike it's gonna
work tonight i'm also taking portland
first quarter and first half i don't
think they can hang for all four
quarters with the lakers but i do think
they're going to step up big early on in
james absolutely i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm baffled right now by the
bad vibes that kelly just sent me that's
a technical she has to go
she has to she just went away she just
went against my picks
she has to go she has to go
the show i might have to go too
because i believe in the injured player
theory
it makes perfect sense this is how
sports work
they will rally around their injured
player and they're gonna come out hot
i'm not saying they're gonna wait
i'm saying they're gonna come out hot
portland plus 158
absolutely no idea what you're talking
about you just speaking cliches
they're gonna come out hot i'm like
vernon that's not a cliche
i think we need a three-person group
chat yeah
g-money mentioned the okc thunder
earlier in the show i'm rocking with
shea gill just alexander now you got me
stumbling and he's a canadian i should
not get his name wrong shay
steven adams lou dort and uh to to be
the team that gets to 10 first they
they've split the series
2-2 but okc has won to back games they
got the momentum
book it raced to 10 in game five against
houston
i'm rocking with you g mine i like that
that's fun i like that cab
all right can we get kelly and vern back
in the chat let's add them back i want
them to hear a lot for once
in their life i've got them i'm gonna
i'm already gone i got other things to
do like bet games and not listen to well
you could do both at the same time you
can do both
i'm going to ride with greg at minus
230. i like the bucks i think the magic
are toast and i think the blazers are
toast i'm gonna take the lakers
first and ten as well a little parlay
special so i don't so i'm not such a
chalk eating weasel as kelly likes to
say
that pays out plus 113 on fanduel i love
it let's get it
all right i like that mike besides
mikey's idiotic
bozo jabroni pick i need
you guys to vote for the pick in the
comments we're gonna
again ride it together as a family and
if you want to know how
important these quick hitter bets are to
us into our family
check out this dude at my cojones yes
that's his ig name
whatever he was betting nerfius with us
while his wife
was having a baby that's right
incredible
we doubled down with the boys we got the
baby we got the money
now we just need olive garden some bread
sticks let's go
love that dude love that dude shout out
to your new wife michael honest
kelly kelly he got them rich the bet hit
you wouldn't be mad i mean you could buy
me a really good push present if you're
pulling that kind of stuff in the
delivery room
if it's a family that quick
legend or loser right that guy's a
legend absolutely i mean
that guy's a legend the baby was born
into good vibes like what's wrong with
that
oh my god all right what are we getting
i want to give some hoodies away uh d
schultz ii says he loves the parlay
uh you get a hoodie for that one just
because i'm feeling nice today
uh daryl deal 218 says mikey is tweaking
that's not very nice i'll give you a
hoodie for that though i want to spread
the hate around
i i don't know i'm having a really tough
time trying to go through these comments
and figure out who won
you're done with the comments i'm about
to ask if i can take over the comments
no you just me i'm the only one in the
comments
uh the last comment from cancun on three
says bucks greg's on the bucks you know
he's the tenney god
we're gonna ride with the bucks tonight
bucks okay a race to ten winners
still gonna bring you on the thunder do
you read
okay yeah no i can't
portland all hello good luck to these
gentlemen on their
minus 2 30 tinney no kelly yeah
got it you have to bet it that's a rule
literally
i'm on the bus we have to do it all
right remember what we taught you here
today
cabbie hit up kelly for your locks
probably just good life advice in
general
take the underdog you love even if you
know
or take your home team we are hammering
the bucks tinny follow us at br
betting there yes yes yes when and when
you guys follow us
when you guys follow us on br betting on
ig make sure you guys check out the ig
live me and my guy cabby is going to be
holding it down for the bucks tinny
today so bring us all the vibes bring us
the breadsticks
bring us dinosaurs bring us star emojis
bring us all type of vibes
uh cause we're gonna need it couple more
hoodies i got a couple more hoodies this
guy
go mikey give this guy rocco rick has
said hoodie in the comments like a
hundred straight times
that's not going to get you a hoodie bro
that's the dumbest thing i've ever seen
it's a hoodie mikey no
no hoodie for you uh that's what she
said
name the kid parlay that's a great name
that's a good dog name
a good baby name uh you get a hoodie for
that one i like that
uh mikey parlay's hot on jm you get a
hoodie for that
uh i don't know i feel really good i
just want everyone to feel the vibes
because tonight
we are going to get rich af vern
i love it if you got a hoodie we will dm
you so check
those messages we'll see you next week
and we're leaving the chat
we out